What's up, man? How you doing?
>> What's up? Pretty good. Thank you. How
are you?
>> I woke up today, man, and I saw
something crazy.
>> Jesus was on your mind,
>> huh?
>> Jesus was on your mind.
>> Hell no, bro. The Epstein list got
leaked and Trump was giving head to Bill
Clinton.
>> Can y'all see that?
>> So, you come up here with some weird
stuff? Get off the stage.
>> Watch your head, bro.
>> What's wrong with Muslims, man?
>> They always got some type of
>> weird sexual stuff on their mind. It's
crazy.
What's up, bro?
>> Yeah. What makes you think Jesus is God?
>> He claimed to be God and then
resurrected from the dead like he said
he would.
>> Okay. Um, where does he claim he's God?
>> He says that he's the first and the
last.
>> Okay. How does this prove he's God?
>> Well, this is one of the names of God in
the Old Testament and in the Quran.
>> Okay. So, when he says he's the first
and the last, he's referring to the
alphabetical order. He also says he's
the alphabet.
>> He doesn't the first and last is not an
alphabet, bro. Alpha, Alpha, and Omega
are the
>> I forgot the internal critique. I forgot
the um internal critique on it.
>> What do you mean you forgot the internal
critique?
>> Him being the first and the last. How
does this prove he's God?
>> Uh being the first and last means that
you're eternal and infinite, right?
>> Not spec.
>> Yeah.
>> Um yeah, sure. But in this way, he's not
really in this just really quick. If you
are if you are the first and the last,
then you are God. Correct?
>> Yes. But in this way, he's not saying
he's the first and the last in the way
of God would say it because what he
means by what he means by he's the first
and the last is he's the first to die
and he's the first to res resurrect and
he will have the keys of Hades.
>> Was he the first to die?
>> Um he
>> was he the first to die, bro. Come on,
be honest.
>> Well, he he died and then he resurrect.
>> I know he died. Was he the first to die,
bro?
>> By your framework.
>> Was he the first to die?
>> No.
>> Okay. So then that doesn't work then,
right?
>> Okay. So him being the first and the
last makes him God. Correct.
>> You would agree with that, right? You
you agree with that?
>> Not really. No.
>> Okay. So who So you're a Muslim. You're
a Muslim, right? Hold on. You're a
Muslim, right?
>> Hold on. Wait. Wait. Let me speak.
>> No. I I just did it. You're a Muslim,
right?
>> I would contradict.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> You're a Muslim. Okay.
>> Alhamdulillah. Yes.
>> Who is the first and the last? My
brother.
>> God.
>> All right. So if somebody claims to be
the first and the last, they're claiming
to be God, right?
>> Yes. But in this way, in this sense,
he's not saying it the way God would say
it.
>> Is he not saying it the way that God
would say it? Because you're so Hold on.
Let's Hold on. Hold on. Before you get
before you get to something else,
>> stay focused, Habibi. Stay focused.
>> You said that the first and the last is
God. And if somebody claims to be the
first and the last, they're claiming to
be God.
>> Jesus claimed to be the first. Slow,
slow down. Jesus claimed to be the first
and the last. But all of a sudden when
it comes to Jesus, when he says he's the
first and the last, he's not claiming to
be God because of some miracle Muslim
interpretation.
>> Okay. Okay. In the Bible, let me let me
show you why your point is redundant. In
the in the bib in the biblical
scriptures, many many people claim that
to be gods, such as Moses. Does this
mean they're actually God? Yes or no?
>> Can you show me that? Show me where
Moses claimed to be God.
>> He claim he claims to be Lord. He claims
to be Lord.
>> Show me what you said. Moses claimed to
be God. Can you show me that? I said um
I said many bibl in in the biblical
>> Yeah. You said many of them and one of
the and the first person you named was
Moses. So do you have the verse and the
chapter?
>> Let me bring up Yeah. Let me bring you
up one second.
>> All right. Go ahead. Get the verse. I
don't want your interpretation. I only
listen at Bible. That's the truth.
>> That's the truth.
>> This is Islam, ladies and gentlemen. He
didn't even have to say he was a Muslim.
I just knew he was a Muslim by how word
puts it, by his cadence.
>> By his vernacular. By his vernacular.
There it is. By his vernacular. That's
how I just knew he was a Muslim. He
didn't even say he was a Muslim yet. By
his vernacular. I already knew K was a
Muslim because only only Muslims would
argue like this. They would argue um I
mean, you know, Jehovah's Witnesses and
other Unitarians and wonders, they also
are like they struggle with cognitive
dissonance as well. But man, with
Muslims, it's just like a there's a way
that they do it. There's a there's a
style of cognitive dissonance that
Muslims have and express that's just
unique, you know. So, it's uh it's
amazing. Kuram,
>> yo,
>> what's up?
>> Yo, what's up, man?
>> What's up, man? The Bible clearly
teaches that Jesus is God. Bro, you
disagree?
>> Yeah. Yeah, of course I disagree. I'm a
Muslim, man.
>> That doesn't mean that you can't can't
be honest with the text of the Bible.
No, no. I could definitely be honest
with the text of the Bible and all the
historical evidence that there is to,
you know, put beside it, but
>> bro, like how do you sit there talking
about cognitive dissonance
>> from Muslims on Tik Tok, bro?
>> Like on Tik Tok, bro, and you be ducking
Libyano, bro. Like, come on,
>> man. You that you got a good point, bro.
You got a good point.
>> Like, if like, bro, you smart. I'm not
I'm not trying to be rude. You're smart.
to to go with your point to go with your
point. To go with your point, bro. To go
with
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um,
>> you know, I had a whole live, man. I had
a whole live where um Liiano was
supposed to come and and join me and
have a conversation and he dodged me.
Why you think he did that?
>> Yeah. You talking about when uh when he
was on his way to his office?
>> When I when I waited 20 minutes for him
when he said that he would join my live
immediately. Why? Why? Why he do No, I
mean I don't remember him in the clip
saying immediately because he
>> Oh, you don't? Of course you don't. I I
know because you're a Muslim. As a
Muslim because because he didn't say
he's as a Muslim he didn't say he's
going to get on immediately.
>> Kuram, it's okay if you if you can't be
honest with your boys, then there's
nothing for us to talk about, man.
>> Yeah. So, I I just told you that he
didn't say immediately. He get off the
stage.
>> Maybe Learn edited that part out.
>> Oh, he did. He definitely edited edited
it out, but it's live.
>> When I'm off the panel for too long, he
kicked me out. But anyways,
>> that's true.
>> Exodus 7:1.
>> All right. I'm I'm going to ask you to
be honest with the verse. Does Moses say
that he's God there?
>> No. But God says he's God, bro.
>> So, God says that you will be as God to
Pharaoh and Aaron, your prophet, right?
Yes.
>> Okay. So, so Moses doesn't claim to be
God, right?
>> Okay. Him not claiming to be God doesn't
mean it's not predicated onto him. It's
been Wait, wait, wait. Let me finish.
Let me finish.
>> You said No, I'm sorry, bro. You said
that there's many prophets that claim to
be God in the Bible.
>> So that was a false claim, right?
>> The higher being has predicated
>> off the radar. I'm going to ask you to
be honest or I have to move on. I cannot
do the dishonesty. There's only so much
I can handle. You said that the previous
prophets all claimed to be God. Was that
the truth?
>> No, no, no. You don't need a second. Was
that the truth?
>> All right. What was your question?
Sorry, I had to do something. What was
your question? [snorts]
>> Yo,
>> take care of yourself. Watch the clip
back, man. Facts. What's up?
>> Hello.
>> Yo, God Logic.
>> What's up?
>> Um, as a Muslim, like, could you explain
the Islamic dilemma to me?
>> The Quran says that the Bible is true
while at the same time contradicting the
Bible and so therefore it makes false.
>> Why can't I just appeal to a general
confirmation? Because the Quran says
that you have to believe in all of the
scriptures. Chapter 2:85, it says, and
by the way, a general confirmation means
that you're confirming the whole of a
thing. When you say in general, you're
talking about the whole of something,
not a piece of something. So they're
they're even giving you the wrong
terminology for saying, "Oh, it's a
general confirmation." Well, general
means it's confirming the whole of it.
So, yeah.
>> Okay. Cuz that's what I've been hearing
from a lot of my Muslim brothers. They
would say general confirmation that
stuff and that that really didn't sit
right with me.
>> Yeah. Um, you got your Quran on you?
>> Uh, no I don't, but I'm I'm close on my
computer.
>> Okay. Go to go to chapter 2 verse 85.
This will debunk this entire idea that
you that that the Quran only confirms
pieces of scripture. Go to chapter Go to
chapter 2 verse 85.
>> I got you. Uh, Surah Alakar.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah. You want me to read it?
>> Yeah. But here you are killing each
other and expelling some of your people
from your homes. Aiding one another in
sin and aggression. And when those
expelled come to you as captives still
ransomed them, though expelling them was
unlawful for you. Do you believe in some
of the scripture and reject the rest? Is
there any reward for those who do so
among you and other than disgrace in
this worldly life? Okay.
>> You see that does Allah like people who
pick and choose what part of the
scripture they believe in?
>> Nope.
>> What does he say is going to happen to
those type of people who do that?
They're going to have the hardest
harshest punishment on the day of D,
>> which is hellfire. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, if you if you go on with this
so-called general confirmation,
[clears throat] meaning that you're
believing in parts of the scripture and
rejecting other parts that just disagree
with you, then you're going to go to
hell according to Allah.
>> Okay, I get you now.
>> Yeah. So, they're go everything they say
is opposite of what the Quran says.
Everything they say.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So,
>> I appreciate you, bro.
>> Of course, man. If you have more
questions, you can come up anytime, man.
>> All right. Thanks.
>> All right. Peace.
>> I'm not sure he was a Muslim, but Okay.
>> If he wasn't a Muslim, man, and you
know,
>> cuz usually Muslims give some sort of
push back even if they don't know the
argument. You know what I'm saying?
Like, I'm not sure.
>> Yeah. Word Word knows how to wield them,
so he would know.
>> That's [clears throat] right.
>> What's up, brother?
>> What's up, [laughter] man? How you
doing?
>> All praises. All is well. All praises.
Yes, sir. All praises to the most high.
So, what do you think of the topic?
>> Very powerful, man. Look at my screen.
>> It's too small for me to to see it. But
what does it say?
>> Oh, you can't see it?
>> No. What does it say?
>> Okay. Well, this is John 20:1 17. It
says, "Jesus said unto her, touch me
not, for I am not yet ascended to my
father, but go to my brethren and say to
them, I ascend unto my father and your
father, and to my God, and your God."
Oo, that's powerful there. What do what
do you get out of that?
>> Well, and uh I want to go to this is
Revelation, the book of Revelation. This
is chapter 5 and uh verse 7. Hold up.
I'm on the wrong page. All right. This
is chapter 5 verse 7. Well, I think we
need to start at the beginning because
this is talking about Jesus.
>> If I were you, let's let's do one verse
at a time. You you brought up John 20.
What what did you understand from John
20:17?
>> John 20 verse 17. That's that's that's
what you just quoted.
>> Hard to get out of.
>> That's hard to get out of I think for
anyone. It says I am He said I ascend
unto my father and your father and to my
God and your God.
>> What do you do?
>> That Jesus is not ascending to himself.
>> I [snorts] agree with you. He's
ascending to his father. But what is
what what do you take about Jesus from
that? Do you are you saying that he's
not God? He's not divine.
>> I say I say God put his spirit on him
like the book of Isaiah 11 say but
according to this he say but go to my
brethren and say unto them I ascend to
my father and your father and to my God
and your God. I don't think we could get
around that. Like
>> but get around what what what is what
exactly is this saying?
>> Like uh Jesus is God. Change my mind.
And Jesus, you know, he has the spirit
of God on him, but he can't do nothing
without the power of the father.
>> Okay. So, are you saying that this verse
shows that Jesus is not God? Is that is
that what you're saying? Saying
>> absolutely. Absolutely.
>> Can you read verse 28?
>> 28. Okay. It says, "And Thomas answered
and said unto him, my Lord and my God."
>> Who's he talking to?
>> He's talking to the Messiah and God. He
said, "And my God."
>> Yes. He says, he's talk, he calls Jesus
his Lord and his God.
>> And then watch what Jesus says. Does
Jesus rebuke him in the next verse or
does he affirm what he says?
>> Jesus said unto him Jesus said unto him,
"Because you have seen me, you have
believed. Blessed are they that have not
seen and yet have believed."
>> So Jesus didn't rebuke him. He affirmed
him. But he was like, "You only believe
this cuz you've seen me. But blessed are
those who believe without seeing me,
right? that he's this Lord and God. So
the same chapter that you quoted from
say shows that Jesus is God. All right?
>> It says Jesus said unto Thomas because
you have it says and Thomas answered and
said unto him, my Lord and my God.
That's that's a powerful one to come
against what I just showed you. I can't
even lie. That's [laughter] a powerful
one
>> against what I just showed you.
>> I want to go
>> I'm not using it to show you
>> I want to bring clarity. I'm not using
it against what you showed me. I'm using
it to clarify what you showed me. Okay.
I believe the verse that you showed me.
I believe it 100%. That Jesus is going
to the father who is his God. Now, but
you need to understand that this doesn't
take away from Jesus himself being God
as well. Let me say why. If you go to
Jeremiah 32:27, the scripture says that
God is the God of all flesh, right? He's
a God of all flesh. Now Jesus who was
the word of God took on flesh which
would mean that the father becomes his
god in that way. That's the relationship
that he has.
>> It says it says saying to a stock you
are my father and to a stone.
Oh you said ver you said
>> chapter 32 chapter 32.
>> Oh 32. I was at two. Pardon me.
>> I got uh 32 and 27. It says, it says,
"Behold, I am the Lord, the God of all
flesh. Is there anything too hard for
me?"
>> Yeah. So God says he's the God of all
flesh. That would include Jesus when he
takes on flesh, right? The word who took
on flesh. Yep. So Jesus, who is the
word, took on flesh. And so therefore,
the father, since the God is the God of
all flesh, the father becomes his God
once he takes on flesh. That's why Jesus
in the flesh can say that I'm ascending
to my father and your father, my God and
your God. Jesus is in flesh. So the
father is his God in that way. But Jesus
also shares the same nature as the
father as being God himself. They share
the same divine essence. While they are
distinct in their personhood and Christ
humbles himself to the father in role as
a servant, but they're equal in nature
because they're both God in that same
chapter, John 20.
>> Okay.
>> So go ahead. I want I want you to I want
you to enlighten me on this because this
is a another stumbling block of mine.
>> Okay.
>> So, you know, maybe you could give me
some clarification on uh Revelation 5.
You know, I'm about to read it. I'm
about to read it right quick. It says,
>> this is uh Revelation 5 and 4. It says,
"And I wept much because no man was
found worthy to open the book and to
read." It said to no man was found
worthy to open and to read the book,
neither to look thereon. And one of the
elders said unto me, "Weep not. Behold,
the lion of the tribe of Judah, the root
of David, and prevailed to open the
book, and to loose the seven seals
thereof. And I beheld, and lo, in the
midst of the throne, and of the four
beasts, and in the midst of the elders
stood a lamb, as it had been slain,
having seven horns and seven eyes, which
are the seven spirits of God sent forth
into all the earth. And he came and took
the book out of the right hand of him
that sat upon the throne. It says, "The
slain lamb came and took the book out of
the right hand of him that sat upon the
throne." Please uh give me some
clarification or some elaboration on
that.
>> Can you keep reading the verse 13? 13
and 14. Read verse 13 and 14.
>> Yes, sir. It says, "And he came and took
the book out of the right hand of him
that sat upon the throne." You said, go
straight to it. Verse 13 and 14.
>> Yeah, verse 13 and 14. It's going to
answer you. It says, "And every creature
which is in heaven and on the earth and
under the earth and such as are in the
sea and all that are in them heard I
saying, bless and honor and glory and
power be unto him that sit upon the
throne and unto the lamb." So it's one
that sit on the throne and is a lamb
forever and ever. Huh?
>> Correct. Now read verse 14.
>> Okay. And the four beast said, "Amen."
and the four and 20 elders fell down and
worshiped him that live forever and
ever.
>> So you see that they're not only
worshiping the the father, the one
that's sitting on the throne, they are
also worshiping the lamb.
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay, but this is okay. Now this is in
heaven. And if Jesus is just a created
being, then that means that there's
idolatry going on in heaven. You think
God is going to allow idolatry in his
most holiest of places amongst them?
>> Absolutely not. Right? So the lamb also
has to be God because they are both at
the throne and all of the living
creatures in heaven and earth and under
the earth and everywhere is worshiping
them simultaneously together.
>> I I I I'm definitely seeing I'm seeing
what y'all presenting and I know y'all
seeing what I'm presenting. So one thing
for sure, two things for sure. This is
some powerful edification that we must
go through.
So we just we just trying to show you.
[laughter] Okay. I know you have a
context and how you like to read it, but
there's deeper meaning and understanding
to the verses that you're reading,
right? So if you just keep reading most
of the Bible, when you have a question,
you just keep reading a little further
and it answers you mo almost 90% of the
time. It's going to answer the because
we interpret Bible with Bible.
>> That's right.
>> All right.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying?
[clears throat]
>> This Isaiah chapter 11. This is the
righteous reign of the branch of Jesse.
We know, we all know uh Jesse is David
father and Jesus was supposed to come
from David line. This say this the
righteous reign of the branch of Jesse.
It say and there shall come forth a rod
out of the stem of Jesse and a branch
shall grow out of his roots and the
spirit of the Lord shall rest upon him.
The spirit of wisdom and understanding,
the spirit of counsel and might, the
spirit of knowledge and of the fear of
the Lord. So God said he going to pull
his spirit on somebody and the spirit of
the Lord shall rest upon him
>> on on the branch of Jesse. Right.
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. Can you go to Jeremiah 23 verse 5?
>> Yes, sir. Okay.
>> What time you getting off of that?
>> I'm about to get off, baby. I'm I'm just
building with the brother. [laughter]
>> I'm about to get off. I'm building with
the brother. You said Jeremiah what?
>> Okay, baby.
>> Jeremiah 23:5. Man, don't get in
trouble, man.
>> Hey, don't get in trouble, big dog.
Look, [laughter]
>> hey, that that's a long time, man.
>> Look. Oh my god.
>> Look, that's a long time, big dog. Look,
I'm I'm live every Monday, Wednesday,
Friday. You could come back, man. I'm
I'm going to read this and I'mma go I'm
unfortunately
read that and then you better get to to
your wife, man. Read
>> Jeremiah what 235.
>> All right. It says, it says, "Behold,
the days come, sayeth the Lord, that I
will raise up unto David a righteous
branch, and a king shall reign and
prosper, and shall execute judgment and
justice in the earth. In his days Judah
shall be saved, and Israel shall dwell
safely, and this is his name, whereby he
shall be called, the Lord our
righteousness."
>> So, who is the Lord our righteousness?
>> Christ. But in that context, who does it
say? If you look in the in the in the
>> David.
>> No, this talking about the branch. This
is talking about the branch off of
David.
>> Well, what I I didn't mean David
specifically. I meant his bloodline,
>> right? But this righteous branch, this
branch from David is going to be called
the Lord our righteousness. Now, if you
look in the Hebrew, it says Yahweh our
righteousness.
>> So, this branch is going to be God
according to Jeremiah 23:5 and 6.
>> Well, all praises to the most high. I'm
going go on. Who is the Most High now?
Who is the Most High?
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> And who is that?
>> From from the context we just was read
from the Revelation to Jeremiah to to uh
Jeremiah 23, who is that that most high
God
>> according to this
>> according to everything we just read,
brother?
>> The branch that shall come out of Jesse.
>> And who is that branch?
>> Jesus the Messiah.
>> That's the most high. You just got it,
brother. God bless you.
>> Praise to the Most High. But we also got
that they are two separate entities.
>> No, these are they're the father and the
son are two distinct persons. We'll
we'll talk about that next time you
come. Okay. They're two distinct persons
while while together unified as the most
high. We'll talk about that next time
you come. Okay.
>> I'm going give you a follow, man.
>> I I believe they share the same essence.
They share the same authority. But you
know the the book say they too
different. They they separate.
>> They say they're not separate. They're
distinct. They're different. But they're
not separate. They can't be separated
from each other.
>> But you're right. There is a distinction
there. You know, the father is the
father, the son is the son. Okay, you're
right about that. There is a difference.
>> All praises to the most high. Thank
y'all for having me, brother. That's why
the trinity is true, man. Jesus is God.
Go ahead. You just You on your way, man.
You're on your way.
>> You close.
>> I'm gonna keep studying. I'mma keep
studying.
>> Yes, sir. All right. Peace,
>> y'all. Have a good night, man.
>> You, too, bro.
>> All right, brother. Okay, that was a
[clears throat] nice guest to have. Nice
guest to have, man. Woke word up.
>> My bad. I I stole probably one of your
only good guest on mute.
>> Nah, as long as the job get done. That's
all I care about. You know, [laughter]
the job get done, we good. You know,
it's Friday, man. It's Friday. I like to
I like to delegate. You know what I'm
saying? I like to delegate on Fridays.
All right, let's um let's bring up
somebody else. Good breakdown word.
That's the word and I, ladies and
gentlemen. Subscribe to the word and I
on his YouTube channel. You just heard
him. How he can just walk you through
the scripture like that. That's our
brother, the word and I. Man, watch your
head, dog. All right. Uh, what's up,
man?
>> Yo, hello. You good?
>> I'm good. How are you?
>> Yeah, good, good, good. So, in the
previous conversation, you said that uh
Jesus has a god. Um, if God has a god,
is why is there not two gods?
>> It's not two gods because he's not a
different god in in essence, just in
relationship and role. So Jesus because
he takes on flesh and God be the father
becomes his God in that way. It's really
true.
>> Yeah. But we share the same Yeah. But we
share the same essence as well. We're
two humans.
>> We're you're we're divisible though,
aren't we?
>> Yeah. So are you talking about space and
time?
>> Space, time, will act. We're all we're
we're separable. But the father and the
son aren't.
>> Okay. So So you're counting by division?
>> I don't know what that means, brother.
Honestly, I'm not the philosoph
philosophical type.
>> Okay. Um are the persons divisible? But
what did I just say?
>> You just told me that we count uh three
humans because we're divisible, right?
>> Do you agree? Do you agree with that?
>> That we can't I mean no I'm so I'm
arguing from your paradigm. I can't by
identity.
>> Do do you agree that we are that we are
three on the stage? Me you word that we
are three different human beings.
>> Yeah. Because we have distinctions. I I
come by identity not division.
>> Okay. But like we're even though we
share the same like human substance or
human essence, we're we are different
human beings, right?
>> Yeah. But I don't believe it's just
because of space and time. I believe
that we have
>> Would you say that that's included in
that though?
>> No, I don't I I reject that counting
method. I I believe that we can count
for using uh any like classical uh
identity for anything. So, I want to ask
you, so um
>> that didn't that didn't answer my
question. If if
>> I literally just did
>> if we're separated by by space and time,
is it possible for us to be the still be
the same human being?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, you do agree that space and
time uh would also separate beings. You
agree with that?
>> But I don't agree with it in in the
essence of like counting using it to
count. We're not we're not talking about
we're not talking about in the
philosophical way of using it to count
necessarily. We're just talking about
what distinguishes different beings.
What makes even though we you and I are
both human, what makes me a different
human being? You would you agree that
our time and our spatial location,
right, would in would include in us
being different human beings?
>> Yeah. But if you were to use the same
Yeah. So, no problem. So if you was to
use the same logic,
>> what about what about act?
>> Yeah, but I'm saying if you were to use
the same um uh evaluation you just gave
for persons in the trinity, you would
count one person because they are not
divisible.
>> No, that's that's they're not divisible
in their being and they're distinct in
their personhood. That's what makes that
>> No, no, I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about the being. I'm just
talking about person.
>> That's what we're talking about.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the
>> you asked you asked how how is it not
two gods. I just I showed I told you
listen you're not tracking. Look look
you
>> don't say I'm not don't say I'm not
tracking. You're doing that.
>> No you're not listen you're not
understanding. Look you told me because
we are divisible. That's why we are two
humans. Right. But I'm telling you that
the persons are not divisible but you
still count three persons. The reason
why I count three persons is because
there's a distinction in their
relationship. But they're not but
they're not but hold on. Excuse me. But
they're not three beings. You asked me
about being. You asked me how is it not
two gods. So you were asking me about
their being their essence. Their essence
is indivisible.
>> Yeah. Dude, look. So when you introduce
distinctions and then [clears throat] I
want you to give me an example of a
distinction within the persons.
>> Well, the father begets, the son is
begotten.
>> Yeah. Okay. So for example, paternity.
Now is that a is that a distinction of
division or is that a distinction of
identity?
>> What do you mean a distinction of
division?
>> Yeah. So when you say a type of uh
distinction would be space and time,
right? They would be sufficient for us
to um say that they're either
inseparable
>> along with will and along with act.
>> Along with will and act.
>> Yeah. I said time, space, will and your
action. That that shows that we are that
shows that we are different. has nothing
to do with like when you say v will act
has nothing to do with um uh it has
nothing to do with division like why you
like you're collapsing you're collapsing
>> yes it does you would would you agree
that um would you agree that if you have
the same will that you are the same
being
>> if you have the same will we are the
same being
>> if your will if your will is identical
yeah one and the same will you agree
that that makes you the same being
>> no
>> okay so you can have the same exact
But be but bey uh two different beings.
>> Yeah. Hypothetically. Yes.
>> How so?
>> I mean what's your argument? What's your
argument if two people share the same
will?
>> Would you agree that why why would why
would that be one human?
>> Can can you share the same will as a
human being? Can you share the same will
as somebody else?
>> No. I'm just talking about
>> Exactly. So why not why why not why
can't you share the same will as another
human being?
>> Yeah. It's just something that just
doesn't happen.
>> Why Why is it impossible? Is it Let me
ask you this. Is it possible for a human
being and another human being to have
one in the same will?
>> No, it's not possible. No.
>> Why?
>> Yeah. Look, it's something that's um
metaphysically
uh not possible. Why?
>> Right. Yeah. It's not to do with because
you'll be the same person. You need to
you need to prove to me that
>> you're not telling me why.
>> No, but if we did share the same will If
we did share the same will, why would we
be the same person?
>> Ask me another question. You need to
tell me why. No, because you need to
prove that.
>> No, you you just made a claim. You just
answered the question and said it's
metaphysically impossible for two
separate human beings to have one and
the same will. Why?
>> No, that wasn't Yeah. No, bro. Look, I
was arguing mainly your counting method.
So, you told me
>> why. Answer the question. Why? Just
answer the question.
>> Dude, the thing is this this question
doesn't make sense. Like, it's a
>> You can say you could say that all you
want. You need to answer the question.
But that's not an escape. Why is it
impossible for two separate human beings
to have one of the same will? Why is
that metaphysically impossible?
>> Yeah, but look, you have to look at it
as God can make two humans and you know
they have the same exact will as
possible. Yeah. If God wants to Are you
saying that God couldn't do that?
>> You said that it was metaphysically
impossible.
>> No, no, I meant logically impossible. So
it doesn't happen in our switching.
>> No, no, look. Just because I misspoke
doesn't mean anything. Look, if if God
was to make humans that share the same
will, why would we count one human? Can
you can you argue with that?
>> All right, so answer the question cuz I
I need you to answer the qu Now now
you're saying it's logically impossible.
You switched from being it being
metaphysically impossible. Now it's
logically impossible. Okay, I got you.
It's lo Hold on a second. It's logically
impossible. So if it's logically
impossible, that means that it fails the
laws of logic, right? It doesn't meet
the standard and criteria for the laws
of logic. Correct?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Can God do something that is
logically impossible?
>> No.
>> All right. So even when you saying, "Oh,
God can, you know, create two human
beings that have one and the same will.
Why not? Why wouldn't The answer is no.
He can't do it according to your
paradigm."
>> Why not? Why is it logically impossible?
>> Yeah. Okay. No problem. I'll answer. I
I'll answer. Look, I'll answer you. No
problem. Look, if two humans were to
share the same will, they would still
have distinctions like a different body,
a different brain, different
experiences, right? Different relations.
So they would still have differences
between them. So we can discern that
they would be not one human but they
would be two humans.
>> That sounds like those that sounds like
hypoatic distinctions to me. But I
didn't hear I didn't hear an essential
distinction. Would they still would they
be one in the same?
>> Yeah. When when you introduced look look
>> will they be one of the same being?
>> This is why Yeah. This is why I was
saying before you weren't tracking
right. So when I when you told me that
we are three humans because we share
>> question. Yeah. One second. You told me
we are three humans because we're
divisible. Then I asked you, okay, the
persons are not divisible. So why?
>> Look, I'm going to get to it. One
second, bro. I already answered.
>> I hope so.
>> Yeah, I already answered you.
>> I I asked you, are they are they two are
they two different human beings still if
they have one and the same will?
>> Yeah. And I told you they would still be
two different humans.
>> Is is will a property of your essence or
is it a property of your personhood?
>> Will it would be a property of my
personhood?
>> Can you establish that? That's crazy.
Can you establish that?
>> What you mean? Can I look when when you
talk about uh what makes a uh a human a
human? It would be, you know, like you
can say your mind, soul and all the
essential properties that you need for
you to be what you are, right?
>> So are those are those essential
properties or have
>> my mine? Yeah, they'll be essential
properties. Mine and your will
differing. So you just you just brother
you just said that your will is a
property of your essence. It's an
essential property. It's not an not a
property of the person when you just
said you just said that.
>> Hey brother, I'm I'm going to go ahead
and just let this go brother. You take
care of
>> Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> My god.
>> He's doing the classical he's doing the
classical uh conflating persons and
natures type thing. You know essence and
and persons.
>> He didn't know the difference. He didn't
know the difference between the two the
two sets of properties. The properties
that make up your essence that belong to
your essence and the properties that
belong to your personhood or hypo or
hypothetic property. He didn't know the
difference. That's why he was slow to
answer and kind of trying to do the
waffle. That doesn't work here, guys.
That doesn't work here, man. Not with
me. That might work with somebody else.
And I'm not a philosophical buff. I'm
not that guy. But I just asked the right
questions. Oh my gosh, man. He just he
said that will is not a property of your
essence. It's a property of your person.
But then described that that will is a
property of your essence. It's what
makes you what you are and your soul,
your mind, all of that. Come on, bro.
[laughter]
[gasps]
Oh, man. Good stuff. Oh, thanks Qtop.